you recorded this new special word you
record the special in Portland Portland
you like Portland love Portland order
good what's not to like
but I could never live there because I
have a purebred dog and I'm pretty sure
they're illegal up do you think you
can't have a purebred dog well they're
super rescue it I have rescues too so
don't get all mad at me rescue people
because I also rescue dogs I rescued my
purebred dog from a breeder they're not
yeah have you ever met a breeder they're
out of their goddamn minds yeah this
woman just lived out in the desert and
she bred Bernese Mountain Dogs and guns
went through a compound and got my
Bernie's and I get court here in LA you
know because the purebred thing I was at
the dog park with my beautiful Bernese
and there was this woman like with for
like monster dogs or whatever I'm super
sensitive to the rescues right and she
sees my dog and right away I see your
eyes I'm like oh God and she says this
is woman stranger says this to me she
goes did you buy her and I go yeah yeah
I did she goes oh I don't know choir
dogs I friend them where to god i
unfriended the debtor like I said I love
rescuing dogs I have two rescues but I
have to apologize for them all the time
because they're both nuts yeah my male
pees everywhere my female tries to
everything and I just constantly have to
go sorry she's a rescue
and anytime anybody ever says to me hey
sorry my dog's a rescue I'm always like
no cuz like why would you buy a
three-legged dog you know I get up with
for like so it's a big thing in Portland
you think they go to lose yeah you
haven't I don't like you've really
looked into it no so I was up there and
I was doing all these jokes about the
rescue thing and I was I was at a
restaurant in Portland hipster place and
I was having this apple pie and it was
super delicious and I said the lady hey
this apple pie is amazing like what kind
of apples and she's like oh they're
rescue apples we don't buy apples or
grow them we wait till they fall from a
tree and then we rescue that like that's
stealing so I've been doing this joke
for a little while right and I was
taping my special in Portland and a
buddy of mine he's from up there and I
go he goes hey are you gonna do that
rescue Apple thing and I go yeah yeah
and he goes well you know that's a real
thing now they actually have rescue
apples in Portland Conan it is
impossible for me to think of a thing to
dumb for Portland AB rescue apples
saying you can't think of a joke that
wouldn't actually be real right like oh
how about a cruelty-free bacon and it's
suicidal pigs and what we do make it
real nice for them we fill them full of
whiskey and we play babe they love babe
let me rub their bellies real thing we
have that secret what about a kazoo band
that just does hair metal covers Motley
Crue's ooh real thing
you